I want to invite you to add something
powerful to your sadaqah jariyah list.
We are on a mission
>> to teach tens of thousands of people
around the world
>> how to pray salah properly.
>> Just imagine this. You help someone
learn wudu, how to pray, how to recite
Surah Al-Fatiha, every Fajr, Dhuhr, Asr,
Maghrib, Isha, Tahajjud, Tarawih, every
prayer for the rest of their lives, you
share in the reward.
>> When they teach [music] their children,
and their children's children, the
reward continues for you.
>> For just £100, you can help teach 20 to
60 people
learn salah. Donate today and earn
rewards that never stop.
BRO, THE CAMERAS.
>> [laughter]
>> MEHANA FAMILY, MEHANA FAMILY.
[laughter]
>> BRO, YOU MESSED UP THAT TRIPOD, AKHI.
SORRY.
>> [laughter]
>> BRO, you need to stay till Fajr.
>> I'm staying till Fajr.
We are teaching people how to pray. And
every time they pray, you get to share
in that reward. And when they teach
their children, and their children's
children,
the reward continues. Every Fajr, Dhuhr,
Asr, Maghrib, Isha, Tarawih, Tahajjud,
every recitation, you share in the
reward. For just £100, you can help
teach 20 to 60 people
learn how to pray salah. Donate today.
Donate today. Donate today.